what is my fiance's worst habit a he  leaves pans to soak on the side for days  B he murders my songs in the shower like  sings them well yeah like he'll or slams  them no no no like he like  okay gotcha okay  I'm going based off what I would do I'm  gonna go with a  Lake pan soaking next to the dish these  bands to soak on the side for days no  it's see he leaves floss all around the  house  I don't floss enough so that's why I use  the water pick right the water yeah yeah  yeah I couldn't I should get him that  for Christmas then there won't be any  glass you know you've solved my problem  you can probably say strawberry stuffer  I'm a therapist that's what I'm here for  wow yeah how do you feel how does it  make you feel  vulnerable good okay